bonjour à tous en aujourd'hui au mwc sur
le stand de nokia pour parler d'une eau
qui a huit scirocco et vous allez voir
c'est une bête de course
[Musique]
nokia a lancé plein de produits super
sympa super excitant ce mwc 2018 et
celui là je dois avouer que c'est mon
préféré parce que c'est vraiment le
modèle le plus haut de gamme nokia 8
scirocco vous avez un écran oled incurvé
qui est vraiment magnifique 5,5 pouces
un écran bord à bord de cars vraiment
top
on les reconnaît de toute façon les
écrans oled t que vous en avez devant
vous vous avez des couleurs qui sont
vraiment beaucoup plus belle en contrat
ce qui est plus profond plus saisissante
la qualité c'est très brillant c'est
très beau et ça vraiment on peut dire
que ce produit est super alors en termes
de prise en main pareil il est super
bien vous avez le capteur d'empreinte
digitale au dos qu'on retrouve très
facilement en termes d'ergonomie c'est
vrai qu'il est super au dessus vous avez
un double appareil photo certifiée zeist
qualité de photo qui est vraiment
irréprochable une caméra 12 mégapixels
une caméra 13 mégapixels vous avez
l'appareil photo standard et un tel
objectif
pour avoir un zoom optique x 2 à l'avant
comme à l'arrière vous avez un gorilla
glass c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'hyper résistants dont votre téléphone
vous risquez pas en le faisant tomber de
l'éclater sur la face avant
où sont la face arrière alors néanmoins
c'est vrai que c'est mieux quand même de
mettre une coque de protection mais
c'est dommage avec un appareil aussi
beau l'année le cash est entre
guillemets avec une coque mais c'est
vrai que voilà luria glace en termes de
sécurité c'est vraiment génial
c'est un produit qui tourne sous android
one en plus de ça nokia promet des mises
à jour sécurité pendant trois ans donc
lorsque vous achetez votre produit
vous êtes vraiment tranquille nokia
annonce également un microphone qui a
été amélioré pour réduire le bruit
ambiant et pour réduire un petit peu les
pollutions sonores ça c'est vrai que
c'est bien pour les appels téléphoniques
avoir toujours une meilleure qualité
c'est vraiment en tout cas un très bon
point si giga de ram 128 giga de
stockage
effectivement vous pouvez rajouter une
carte microsd et avec 128 giga vous avez
vraiment quoi faire
revel recharger en induction vous avez
sinon de l'usb type c côté audio vous
avez le nokia spatiale audio ce qui fait
que vous pouvez vraiment profiter d'une
immersion sonore en termes des coupes
lorsque vous allez écouter de la musique
lorsque vous allez regarder des vidéos
regarder des films
vous allez vraiment pouvoir profiter
effectivement d'une expérience que ce
soit avec l'écran oled 5,5 pouces n'est
pas effectivement le truc le plus grand
le plus dingue du monde mais 5,5 pouces
amoled ça marche très bien en termes de
jo c'est aussi spatialisé beau qu'on
donnerait vraiment avoir un confort là
je sens le salon s'il est pris en main
j'ai testé on se rend compte
effectivement que ça ça paraît compliqué
ce qui est je suis en tout cas c'est
qu'en le regardant en manipulant aux
premières prises en main
je trouve vraiment séduisant ce qui est
super sympa aussi c'est du côté de la
photo et de la vidéo vous pouvez
effectivement filmé en 4k vous pouvez
voir un partage d'écran lorsque vous
faites des photos et des vidéos c'est à
dire que sur la partie du haut vous
allez avoir la caméra arrière sur la
partie du bas vous allez avoir la caméra
avant vous allez donc pouvoir faire des
photos en vous voyant vous est envoyé en
cause alors on peut imaginer pour un
usage pro ça peut être sympa de dire par
exemple je vous montre quelque chose d'à
côté je me contredis à côté même lorsque
vous êtes sur un usage de la particulier
avec des amis je ne montre avec ce que
je vois et je montre ma tête de la cote
et ça c'est vraiment hyper sympa ça
évite de faire des montages c'est très
rapide très pratique vous pouvez faire
du facebook live également en montrant
vote fait en montrant ce que vous filmez
vous pouvez faire des vidéos dans ce
sens aussi
donc ce sont des petites innovations
mais qui en tout cas on ne mérite
d'exister et qu'on retrouve pas ailleurs
en tout cas à ma connaissance je trouve
que c'est vraiment bien alors qu'est ce
qu'on voit avec ce nokia 8 scirocco
c'est vraiment la volonté nokia d'aller
plus loin et se positionner sur les
smartphones oled maintenant le poids un
peu négative si vous voulez c'est
d'avoir uniquement
l'écran 5,5 pouces on aurait pu imaginer
un écran 6 pouces un très grand écran
bon avant non plus cracher dans la soupe
c'est un produit qui est très bien pour
l'instant j'ai pas de tarif je vais
aller chiner un peu plus pour avoir des
infos sans le tarif est sans relief de
sortie je vous mets tout ça dans la
description en tout cas on va vraiment
que nokia est de retour en force avec
différents produits que ce soit le nokia
8800 disque est vraiment le téléphone
idiot 79 euros donc vraiment pas cher le
nokia 6 milliards aussi plein d'autres
produits dans les gammes donc c'est vrai
que là on voit que nokia revient en
force en 2018 encore plus ça c'est
vraiment bien
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous connaissez nokia est ce que
vous avez déjà eu des produits de nokia
soit des produits récents d'étrangers
plus anciens on peut imaginer
effectivement aux 33 10 5 était vraiment
la légende du modèle faceook à marquer
mais tout ça en commentaire bien
évidemment comme d'hab vous avez cédé
pusta vous abonner à rester connectés
parce que ici il ya énormément de trucs
on va boire en faire plus de choses donc
on reste connectés je compte sur vous
vous dire très bientôt sur les écrans
rast cham